[Musique]
c'est une région d'Haïti riche en
histoire dans la commune de Milo se
trouvent les ruines fascinant du château
de Sans-Souci que le roi Henri
Christophe a construit dans les années
1810 il régnait sur le Nord d'Haïti non
loin la formidable citadelle La Ferrière
bâti pour repousser une éventuelle
invasion française c'est elle qu'on voit
en silhouette depuis la cité du savoir
un ambitieux projet conçu et gérer
depuis Montréal par des gens qui veulent
poser les bases d'une Haïti nouvelles
[Musique]
c'est Haïti nouvelles comment c'est
logique par la petite enfance des 3 ans
au centre de la petite enfance et
enfants de paysan locaux apprenne à être
bien dans leur peau à l'aise et confiant
avec les autres sans le moindre complexe
d'infériorité
société n'a rien à envier aux meilleurs
de ces équivalent au Québec il porte le
nom de Paul Gérin-Lajoie pionniers de
l'enseignement est grand ami Magali
Félix directrice adjointe de Lyster
commencé depuis 2016 avec un des enfants
de 3 ans et de 4 ans et puis là
maintenant
notre première promotion et maintenant
en 4e année fondamentale
ok donc les enfants seront en 4e année
fondamentale en septembre prochain
primaire
les enfants du CPE en vacances sont
revenus en classe spécialement pour nous
avec leurs parents ils payent environ 12
dollars par an pour la scolarité c'est
important qu'il participe ils sont très
fière ils sont contents et ils viennent
visiter de temps en temps surtout les
parents qui ont leurs enfants ici et tu
viennes très souvent la petite rose et
lire présente à elle seule les classes
du primaire en vacances également elle
est très fière de savoir écrire l'école
primaire fonctionne quelques places sont
déjà prêtes mais elle est encore en
construction et le secondaire encore
passé c'est la promotion qui a commencé
en 2016 avec les enfants du centre de la
petite enfance qu'ils sont maintenant
arrivé en 3e année qui sera en quatrième
année l'année prochaine ainsi que la
cité du savoir dont l'architecte Samuel
Pierre et professeur à l'École
polytechnique de Montréal bien ce que
l'on vous lancer le prendre ses enfants
la 2000 €
et leur donner des perspectives de vie
sur la longue durée 16 enfants l'argent
au CPE a 3 ans et bien si leurs talents
et le permettent et qu'ils ont la
motivation et ben ils vont pouvoir se
rendre jusqu'au doctorat sans devoir
quitter leurs patients
si le primaire est encore en chantier
l'université elle existe déjà facile
l'enseignement se fait par vidéo dans le
civil haïtienne à l'Institut des
sciences des technologies et des études
avancées d'Haïti blister les quelques
200 professeurs bénévole se trouve au
Canada est dans plusieurs universités
d'Europe il y a déjà
le 28 mai dernier c'était notre 4e
cérémonie de collation des grades on a
diplôme et 50 personnes qui dans les 50
il y avait 6 docteur il y avait 20
maîtrise et 24 diplôme d'études
supérieures spécialisé
et adapt nous avons diplôme et plus de
110 étudiants
et ma projet c'est d'arriver sur une
période de 10 ans a formé le certificat
pour le pays
[Musique]
le projet a germé après le grand séisme
de 2010 dans l'esprit d'une vingtaine de
personnes de Polytechnique d'origine
haïtienne et québécoise
enchanté également le futur centre de
santé qui sert des écoles
professionnelles deux ingénieurs et
forme des ouvriers de la construction
qui plus loin fabrique des blocs de
ciment les meilleurs de la région dit en
note ils vendent des surplus 1 dollar
piece viendra ensuite l'école supérieure
des affaires dans ton voilà fondation
plus loin nous avons conçu les écoles
supérieures les affaires et de
l'entrepreneuriat pour ramasser ces
idées qui sont porteuses de création de
richesse pour pouvoir donner à travers
les entreprises et en entreprise
accélérateur de l'entreprise pour les
entreprises d'abord pour les étudiants
qui sont formés mais également les
personnes de la région sur les 42
hectares donné par la municipalité de
Mino s'ajouteront au secteur scolaire
une ferme pour l'école d'agriculture une
zone de service avec centre de santé et
une centaine de logement et enfin
secteur universitaire qui sera le siège
de lister à qui fonctionne déjà mais à
distance
[Musique]
l'école primaire est déjà bien avancé
voici en 3D de quoi elle aura l'air
l'avancement de ce grand projet est
tributaire des événements en Haïti qui
perturbe l'arrivée des matériaux il y a
le financement également seul
enseignement universitaire de lister à a
reçu de l'aide du CRD le Centre Fédéral
de recherche pour le développement
international le reste est assurée par
des particuliers et citoyen du Québec et
d'Haïti il en faudrait plus un projet
prendre la cité du savoir n'a pas
attirer l'attention des organismes
habituel finances et ça ça pose des
questions sur la conversation ça pose
des questions est-ce qu'on a toujours
miser au bon endroit pour United
nouvelle il faut des citoyens nouveau
dit Samuel Pierre et c'est ici qu'on les
formes d'élevage et c'est que les
Haïtiens non pas la patience de faire
c'est de tir dans le temps
ça veut dire prendre le temps de mettre
en place un système éducatif qui forme
de bons citoyens les quel bon citoyen
incarné les nouvelles institutions que
l'on reconnaît ses futurs nouveau
citoyens c'est à Millau non loin du
Cap-Haïtien dans le Nord souvent
négligée du gouvernement et non pas dans
la capitale Port-au-Prince qu'on a
choisi d'implanter ce modèle que les
habitants en huit adopté et qu'il
protège parce qu'il dit crois
[Musique]